i got a question to ask you this
question
what is your pain tolerance dog oh it's
not anything special i don't think i
mean
are you did are you saying that with a
straight face to me
well yeah because it's you are stevo you
telling me you're based
but when i'm in pain you see the
reaction if i didn't feel the pain there
wouldn't be a reaction and it wouldn't
be
the in the entertainment you know it
would be good tv right
it's not my pain
tolerance which sets me aside it's uh
just how much of an attention [ __ ] i
really am that i'm willing to put myself
into that
situation that's why but i wouldn't say
it's an intention because when you got
those third degree burns you were still
working and that was the worst pain
you've ever been in your life yeah i
would have been day one i would day zero
hour one i would've been in the hospital
we went to do a show he did two or three
shows stand up he's typing on the
computer he's like ah
just typing this is before going to get
uh emergency skin graft surgery the
doctor's like how long have you been
like this for and he's like five days
and they're like you have to have
emergency surgery now how would you how
are you sleeping at night how are you
even sleeping it was tough man that that
was a tough one yeah that's real tough
so you
i don't know about any of that i mean
and and yeah i definitely haven't you
know put gone through pain like as a
sober guy i've never uh filled a
prescription for painkillers
so like with tylenol and advil i've
gotten through all kinds of post-surgery
[ __ ] yeah no dog you got you got a
different tolerance bro you i think
there is a tolerance there perhaps
probably probably not as big as most
people would think
it does twist your nipple right now
[Applause]
at the meet and greet and i've never
seen you get more pissed
i couldn't believe it and his reaction
did yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]